Mad Men is one of the greatest shows in
television history but it's ending
prompted quite a bit of debate all these
years later were still discussing what
exactly happened in that last episode
but now we think we finally understand
the ending of Mad Men in Lost Horizon
the 12th episode of Mad Men 7th and
final season Don Draper decides to take
a road trip he does so after attending a
pitch meeting at McCann Erickson where
he feels lost irrelevant and
disinterested Don exits the meeting
shortly after it begins gets in his car
and just starts driving and he doesn't
tell anyone where he's going
at the start of person-to-person the
14th episode of the seventh season and
the final episode of the show we learned
that Don has made it all the way to Utah
and he's racing across the desert it's
miles away both literally and
figuratively from where were used to
seeing him embracing his inner
greasemonkey Don opts for a Canadian
tuxedo in lieu of one of his signature
business suits Draper no longer feels
like he belongs in New York's
advertising world and he's on a mission
to discover where he truly belongs soon
enough he discovers his destiny isn't to
break the land speed record in the Utah
desert Pete Campbell only shows up in
two short scenes in the finale but
they're both essential to his overall
character arc throughout most of Mad
Men's Run Pete was unbearably smug
selfish and insincere a man like you I'd
follow him to combat blindfolded and I
wouldn't be the first my right buddy
let's take it a little slower but in a
madman's final season Pete begins to
change for the better in the penultimate
episode of Mad Men he manages to patch
things up with his ex-wife Trudy he also
takes a new job with Learjet that
requires moving to Kansas so he'll be
starting a whole new life with his
family in the scene where Pete says
goodbye to Peggy he's all smiles and
clearly has no ulterior motive keep it
up you'll be a creative director by 1980
sounds like a long time it's a complete
180 from his sleazy first encounters
with Peggy in the series premiere while
you're in the city now wouldn't be a sin
for us to see your legs if you pull your
waist in a little bit you might look
like a woman moral of the story people
can change and so can weasel x' dons fun
in the Sun is quickly squashed by some
terrible news
he calls his daughter Sally too
excitedly tell her about his adventures
but she's not interested
uh-huh 622 miles an hour in a car that
look like a jet Kelly eventually Sally
tells her dad that Betty her mother and
Don's ex-wife
has been diagnosed with terminal lung
cancer Don immediately says he'll
returned to New York so Sally and her
two younger brothers can move in with
him
but Sally discourages him from doing so
undeterred Don calls Betty and tells her
the same thing I don't want you to worry
about them they're going to come live
with me you don't even have to ask I
wasn't going to
Betty is seeing things more clearly as
she approaches death what they really
need is a woman in their life a regular
family living with my brother and Judy's
and their best interests
Betty reminds Don that he's never really
been a good father to his children it
finally hits him that he's not the
family man he always thought himself to
be this revelation hits him hard despite
the fact that Betty is dying and Don is
effectively out of their lives we still
get the feeling that the Draper kids
Sallie Jean and Bobby are gonna be all
right
Sally seems intent on not turning into
her parents and her predicament forces
her to grow up fast after speaking with
her dad on the phone the eldest Draper
child surprisingly returns home from
boarding school canceling a trip abroad
to do so to help raise her two younger
brothers after telling Jean to leave the
room she has a brief discussion with
Bobby about their mother's health
although Bobby hasn't been briefed on
Betty's illness he knows she's dying and
he's been trying to pick up the slack
around the house he just failed at
cooking dinner as Sally comes home so
she decides to show him a few tricks of
the trade the last time we see Sally
she's washing dishes while Betty smokes
at the kitchen table it's obvious that
Sally is determined to give her brothers
a proper upbringing despite the best
efforts of Betty and Don she's obviously
got a good head on her shoulders
sometimes people become fantastic
individuals despite their parenting
rather than because of it
Roger Sterling doesn't have a lot to do
in the Mad Men series finale his biggest
contribution in the seventh season and
his final grand act is orchestrating the
sale of Sterling Cooper and partners to
mccann-erickson an older man with no
roots at his new company Roger wasn't
particularly valued at McCann and he
knew it he wasn't the future of the
company and in his mind he didn't have
much of a future at all in the finale he
claims to be entering the final chapter
of his life
and surprisingly he seems totally okay
with that Rodgers final chapter involves
him learning to love again and getting
his finances in order at one point he
visits his old flame Joan Holloway
Harris but not to rekindle a romance
instead he tells her that when he dies
he'll be leaving a substantial portion
of his fortune to Kevin the secret son
they share together
Joan initially resists the offer but
Roger insists claiming the arrangement
was made in a way that won't arouse
suspicion Roger this is an expensive way
to mark your territory Roger also
declares his intention to marry Megan
Draper's mother Marie and the last we
see of Roger he's living a cozy life in
Paris with his new bride at the
beginning of the Mad Men finale Joan is
living it up in Florida with her wealthy
new beau Richard and joined her suitor
retirement without a care in the world
meanwhile Peggy is struggling to get
respect at McCann they both seemed
unsure of what they want to do with
their lives but after having dinner with
her former colleague Ken Cosgrove Joan
believes she has an answer for both of
them ken asked Joan to produce an
industrial film for his company and Joan
decides to hire Peggy to write the
script Peggy is initially reluctant at
least until she hears how much money is
involved I don't have time to moonlight
it's $1,200 for a 10 page script jeez
well meeting her friend the project goes
swimmingly allowing Joan to secure more
contracts for similar jobs as she
realizes how much she's been missing
work Joan flirts with the idea of
starting her own industrial film
production company Harris Olson any two
names to make it sound really
are you serious
Peggy has been increasingly unhappy at
McCann so she begins considering Joan's
intriguing proposal but will she go for
it as part of his convoluted backstory
Don Draper or to call him his real name
Dick Whitman befriended Anna Draper the
widow of the real Don Draper whose
identity dick stole during the Korean
War and remained Don's closest friend
and confidante until her death in season
four and by proxy Don also became close
with Anna's adult niece Stephanie Don
shows up at their house in La dreadfully
hungover and depressed and Stephanie
isn't doing so hot herself having just
given up her baby and feeling lost she's
about to head to a hippie retreats on
the California coast
Don having nothing better to do decides
to go along with her upon arriving at
the retreat Don is instantly put off by
all the new-age
shenanigans even though he's trying to
discover who he is he's still a
conservative straight-laced guy at heart
and he seems to think the whole retreats
is rather silly later one attendee
criticizes Stephanie for giving up her
baby what I feel when I hear about your
baby is sadness Don attempts to console
Stephanie but it doesn't go well you're
not my family to make matters worse
Stephanie takes Don's car in the middle
of the night leaving him alone in every
possible way throughout the Mad Men
finale it seems like Joan is trying to
have it all
she wants her carefree relationship with
Richard but she's also excited by the
prospect of starting her own business
it all comes to a head when Richard
calls her out on her career aspirations
essentially asking her to choose between
him and her fledgling business seems
like this might be a chance to build
something well it's gonna take all your
time all your energy and all your
attention at the end of the scene
Richard wishes her luck and literally
walks out of her life leaving Joan
single and ready to mingle with
businesses that need industrial videos
that is the fact that Joan winds up in
charge of her own business is one of the
show's most satisfying developments
after years of being doubted pushed
around and sexually harassed Joan
ultimately decides to be her own woman
and charter own course upon learning
that stephanie has fled the hippie
retreat Don has a complete and utter
meltdown
alone and abandoned in a strange place
Don silently reflects on everything he's
lost he's walked away from his career
feeling like he no longer belongs there
he's recently split up with his wife
Megan who wants nothing to do with him
his first ex-wife Betty is dying and
also wants nothing to do with him and
he's effectively had his kids taken away
from him now to top it all off he's been
abandoned and betrayed by someone he
considered part of his family in this
desperate place Don calls the only
person he thinks might care about him
Peggy Olson she initially lashes out at
him where the hell are you Dawn's former
protege changes her tune once Don starts
crying expressing regrets about all the
mistakes he's made in his life Peggy
tries to talk him down fearing that he
may be suicidal those fears certainly
aren't laid to rest when Don says he's
calling to say goodbye he then abruptly
ends the call by saying he just wanted
to hear her voice well you've seen Don
breakdown before but never like this
Peggy is naturally freaked out about her
conversation with Don and so she gives
Art Director Stan Rizzo a jingle he
emphasizes that Don is prone to taking
off without telling anyone
assuring Peggy that he'll come back
eventually suddenly whiplash Stan
abruptly drops a truth bomb on Peggy I
want to be with you I'm in love with you
the admission takes Peggy completely by
surprise and at first she doesn't even
understand what Stan is saying after all
she's had a lot on her mind her status
at McCann Jones business proposal her
wayward boss she hasn't really taken any
time to think about her romantic life
earlier in the episode Stan tells Peggy
there's more life and work now Peggy is
starting to see what he's talking about
and when she takes a moment to consider
her feelings here's what she comes up
with they can't believe this they think
I'm in love with you too
soon enough they kiss and embrace it's
the finales biggest bit of fan service
which doesn't make the moments any less
satisfying after speaking with Peggy Don
sits alone staring into space until a
member of the retreat comes along and
invites him to sit in on a group session
Don eventually relents during the
session a suburban father who's roughly
Don's age as his own tearful breakdown
as he describes how no one appreciates
him not his family not his colleagues no
one but
I've never been interesting to anybody
Don sees something of himself in the man
and embraces him and they hold each
other and sob uncontrollably
the next morning Don attends a group
meditation outdoors no longer appearing
skeptical cynical or broken-down
Don meditates along with the rest of the
group eventually the faintest hint of a
smile creeps across his face the episode
then cuts to McCann's famous I'd like to
buy the world a coke commercial strongly
suggesting that Don Draper cooked up the
concept right then and there so what's
going on here well one could argue that
Don has finally discovered his true
purpose he pushed away his advertising
career to try and find meaning elsewhere
and he had to lose everything to realize
he really is truly an adman through and
through he's the kind of guy who would
happily exploit IPPY culture as a means
to sell soda made by one of the biggest
corporations in the world hey it's nice
work if you can get it right check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more exclusive looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]